Klauss matech can describe the history
behind every piece of wood here look
funny a messy here get that hide that
hot senior he's even given some pieces
names for 30 years now he's been
researching why every tree has a
different shape and how trees manage to
hold their own weight and stand strong
during storms for the secret it appears
they can sense how they have to grow in
nine flitter now palm the tree senses
itself it thinks here there's a lot of
tension it has a mechanism sensors
otherwise it wouldn't grow and then it
grows thicker tree rings in the right
place until the tension is held evenly
is the base of the trunk has led my tech
to a groundbreaking discovery
he's worked out how trees optimize this
area allowing them to replicate
geometrically with ease and this is how
it works yes the adobo flash oven here
this is the ground and this is our tree
with a corner between them essentially
there's a groove or not a predetermined
breaking point
this here he's acaba the engineers round
this groove with a quarter circle when
table oh there's still tension here
octave so the tree uses another trick
trees will bridge this quarter circle
with a symmetrical triangle Jack Don
neither and then again and again that's
always symmetrical then we smooth this
out and we have the contours of the
triangle line which is a universal form
in nature this happens everywhere in
nature with trees with bones
and even with inanimate objects this
triangle line can be seen like here with
the strange formation of clay and rock
even the Sugarloaf Mountain in Brazil
was formed in the same way the thing
that amazes scientists is that even a
small chain takes the same form at least
when you pull on one end the triangle
line is all over the place
gasps Bible until now optimizing the
shapes after the example of trees was
expensively calculated on computers cows
Montek has developed a universal formula
for the principle of the triangle line
it allows devices to convey the optimal
form without a large computing expense
this saves a lot of time and money with
this new method scientists have been
able to improve medical screws parts for
cars machines and even components for
many consumer goods this device kept
breaking in the same place using the
principle of the triangle line it now
lasts 40 times longer than it used to
it's a tiny change that has had a huge
impact well hot money for you had to
calculate every notch today we can say
here's a nudge this is how much space
you have and with one mouse click the
CAD system can optimize the notches
shape incidentally here's the triangle
line between the thumb and index finger
as a good approximation Yama
nabob GABA or Tonga Klaus Matic has
investigated tens of thousands of trees
all over the world yes and I said your
body said baby the hair stelu
now he knows one thing for sure he still
hasn't done covered all of their secrets
I was law